la médecine du travail à 60 ans et en
croire les médecins qui traquent nos
petits et grands soucis de santé liés à
notre activité professionnelle si les
tâches sont de plus en plus automatisés
et notre productivité plus grande les
maladies ne sont pas moins nombreuses
elles évoluent avec les technologies
comme nous le montre carine azzopardi et
marque sa vie nous celle en quête de ce
19e c'est une histoire de courage de
trop plein de souffrance au travail
j'ai vaincu bois en fait eu de la
fatigue puisque le harcèlement plus les
mêmes problèmes d une prothèse parce que
j'ai bien sûr je force un jeu forcé pour
travail je disais rien le travail
malheureusement pas partout pendant des
années il a caché son handicap pour
conserver son poste
j'ai préféré rater chez moi j'ai ouï
chez moi je suis pas quelqu'un de sain
dimanche je me souviens c'est à dire
avait craqué binger non il y avait du
monde à la maison lui ai des amis de ce
que je suis fort et j'ai pleuré tous et
parce qu'ils savaient clairement la
ville travailler en dix ans déjà j'ai pu
percevoir une aggravation en fait d'eux
des situations de travail avec des gens
qui travaillent peut-être moins et au
niveau des horaires les horaires en
diminuer mais le travail est beaucoup
plus intense physiquement et surtout au
niveau au stress rungis
onze mille personnes s'y activent jour
et nuit aujourd'hui visite de terrain
pour le docteur d'aussi cinq fois par
semaine elle prodigue des conseils
observe les postures rappelle les
visites
comment somme n'est pas calibré partir
du camp ce qu'elle traque ici les tms
troubles musculo squelettiques
c'est la première maladies liées au
travail elle concerne un salarié sur dix
les lombalgies problèmes de dos les
sciatiques les problèmes au niveau des
épaules debout toute la nuit
padoue dans le dos ben si justement on
n'y vient pas le temps que je fais mes
achats bon je vais je marche dans le
pavillon ça va mais dès que je suis sur
mon pupitre pour annoncer mes commandes
ceci cela effectivement la position
debout toute la nuit c'est un peu
pénible mais bon il faut faire que vous
êtes debout tout le temps c'est pas
depuis un tout petit peu les jambes je
crois qu'il y à des conditions de
travail de plus en plus difficile même
si les technologies maintenant son plus
haut point s'il ya une meilleure
protection sur plan individuel la
souffrance au travail augmente mais les
difficultés des travailleurs augmente
les troubles musculo-squelettiques
augmente et manifestement de plus
prendre en compte
ça pose un problème parce que ça met en
cause l'organisation du travail et la
précarité mu en milieu de travail
d'année en année les six médecins de
rungis sont aux premières loges pour
observer l'évolution du monde du travail
et ce n'est pas très rassurant et on est
dans une relation otan qui est
différente il faut il faut très vite
aller mieux quoi il faut très vite gérer
il faut très vite reprendre son poste en
fin et le corps il ne peut pas forcément
suivre quand il ya eu une maladie grave
c'est difficile mieux reconnu ses
médecins ont bien conscience qu'ils sont
la dernière soupape de sécurité dans
l'entreprise
aujourd'hui un tiers des salariés
déclarent éprouver une souffrance liée
directement au travail
en bref